[Music]
how's it going out floor game today
we're checking out another TLC 90-day
fiance couple the fact that this is even
a thing
blows my mind it's so funny we've been
through the ED Andros but now we're
checking out Colt and Larissa
[Music]
my name is Colt I'm 33 years old I live
in Las Vegas Nevada and I dress up my
cats see the thing about Colt is I don't
think I've seen him raise his voice or
get upset a single time in this shop oh
you look so beautiful I work as a
software engineer and I live with my
cats baby girl goddamn that's a creepy
Ken what the hell that's terrifying
this is chillin in the closet the thing
about Colt is that he lives with his mom
and he's over 30 years old by doing
everything around the house I don't
think he even knows how to make a bed
she's saying that that's like a good
thing you clearly haven't taught him to
take care of himself
we'll get into it we'll get into all of
the nuances oh my god guys it's crazy I
thought maybe I could search outside the
country maybe find a girl and then I met
Larissa Larissa lives in Brazil and
she's 31 years old
I can't find the guard in your country
then find a girl online cringe who would
do that I had sent Larissa a message and
to my surprise she actually responded
and we started talking it wasn't long
before I decided I really wanted to meet
her in person so we worked it out and
decided to meet in Cancun Mexico when I
got to the airport in Mexico Larissa
walked around the corner I saw her in
like slow-motion shots of our cheese's
she was the most beautiful when I'm ever
seen I was like I'm done this is it it
was like all the boxes were checked
she's beautiful she's smart and she
seemed pretty cool what's the idea
and she's beautiful she's smart and I
guess guess she's alright
living with my mother Oh after five days
I new spoiler she's not cool with it
what girl likes the fact that they live
with their mom that's the recipe for
disaster I see my tambourine didn't pick
the supreme spell herself
pathetic the comments have no chill as
always if this guy was a spice he would
be flower mr. personality over butter
this guy talks in lowercase oh my god
I'm like I love you too proud are
leaving for the airport I decided to
propose to her
and wise eyes why nice why not propose
after you've just spent a vacation
together that seems like a good
reflection on how you you will get on
for the rest of your life please don't
marry someone before you at least live
with them a little bit because that's a
big adjustment to make it and you need
that to work out for a managed to work
out please stop called honey tell me
please
[Music]
we have no guarantee the reason over I'm
tomorrow or Monday I can't can't make a
ticket have to change for you and make
another ticket here Sam yeah that's
pretty reasonable if you don't know when
you're gonna get the visa you can't just
keep rebook in the flight until you know
what oh she's not happy especially for
like such a short time it doesn't make
any sense
I know you're disappointed and I'm very
sorry for that but you want to put your
heart to me because II I talked to that
to you you feel like oh my god oh my god
I plan to show up in a ball in bed
to bed weeping writing my diary and how
sad I am but it's merely a week probably
less than a week I've been drama drama
drama okay so she finally arrives where
he lives in Las Vegas and a car with no
air-conditioning which sounds awful here
we go and of course she's not happy
about it oh please
Larissa has only been in Las Vegas for
three hours and she's literally not stop
complain since we arrived here Larissa
ha ha you're so silly she's like I'm not
letting this go where's my good flowers
okay
welcome to the desert there's nothing in
Las Vegas unless you go to the strip I
bet you had this image in her head that
is gonna be amazing I get that she
sounds very bratty but it's not that
unreasonable to want flowers after a
long flight first time you see each
other she's coming over to live with him
why am i defending her I don't know
I think Larissa and I will have some
small hurdles to overcome initially I
can't survive here honey I need you to
stop okay just stop I need you to stop
stop talking stop stop
then the comments on her side that's
really interesting here how does that
let her on to think he was Richard
Larissa wanted a sugar daddy but got a
splendid name
what's a Splenda oh that's a artificial
sweetener isn't it Jesus Christ that
woman in the car is terrifying what the
hell I find the ghost oh stop so she
meets with okay honey I think she's a
tiny bit disappointed yeah yeah but
there's a beautiful house it's a
beautiful house look we got the curse
things in the corner and there's no so
far yeah it looks like the mom decorated
the entire house that's what that looks
like Oh God this is a recipe for a
disaster wait until you got here and now
guess what you can pick one out yeah oh
that's nice for me that's nice oh no
she's crying oh no
no she's happy for them okay great bro
if I were her I'd be like okay back to
Brazil this
I mean she's not wrong it looks like an
old mom they courted I think we move to
a new house she just came and she says
we need to move no sensor no shell great
this is great I mean I don't know what
you don't like Las Vegas
you don't like the house you don't like
anything so I'm like okay this guy
straight-up picks her up in a bucket of
a car with no flowers then brings back
to Obama's house my dad bought it for
her that's cute that's a toy it's fun
it's nice you making dinner it's ready
do this money angry I can't watch these
two creams Jesus Christ ed anyways she
calls him colty I need that to call T
you feel for me the thing that speaker
make me to later percenter cold is when
I steal money for by stuffing that's for
example I want to buy a Mel I will move
heaven and earth to make you happy but
sometimes your demands are quite
ridiculous honestly Christ everyone
prepaid credit card for you know maybe
in the middle yes let's go with that
there what a negotiator so in a year she
can almost afford a Chanel bag if she
saves all our money it seems like fair
what's your annual income uh $2,000 per
year I think that I am a good median
dollars from coat okay you want 1
million dollars from cold that'll take
you just 500 months so in 4 to 1 years
it'll get that million so they go over
to meet some of coltish friends yeah
this is Larissa guys get along with
lemon equal to each other and everything
we're doing pretty good there's nothing
pretty good yes no filter
Jesus Christ dude cold has wait what oh
no oh no
in Karachi and in Karachi and the baby
thinks that she show obvious effects the
react said yes intersects hugging
kissing being intimate physically
intimate obviously cuz she has a great
sexual drive together the bed all day
for he is perfect in the coach and he's
live with his mom his entire life of
course colt is gonna want to go
bing-bong you know me I respect that
clothe be fair enough
you can always break this off you can
always break this up in front of our
je-sus Christ no shell
no one got no shield you kills break
this up you're not just coming over here
to marry my man for a green card are you
the green cards is not adjusted the the
right so I live here with him
and he can take the divorce any time
that's what he wants so it's not the
guarantee it's a gamble really I mean
you wanted the pie payoff you want you
know make sure your investment you know
lose all your money right welcome to
Vegas welcome to a famous screwed you
know I think that she's coming to
America to enjoy the you know high life
I don't know where her living situation
in Brazil was but I wouldn't call this
the high life I wouldn't I don't want to
be rude
also for the record no grown man should
share a bank account with his mother
damn people are simpler Larissa what the
hell I did not expect this at all she's
crazy
they then have a barbecue of course it's
great it's gonna go great trust me
[Music]
how was your life hell you have a man
paying for you your man pays for
everything your man pays for everything
because you don't do Jesus Christ and
until you do and you understand respect
is she crying you're not acting this is
a great barbecue guys this is a good
time she's living the high life guys
come on waning don't say that I would
like to take advantage of the co2 this
love because of the vents
what not million
[Music]
you see his body may be cold buddy
yes bigger breasts in mine I like it
very much it's very nice I can't pretend
anymore it's just fake it anymore really
what do you mean love is enduring for
the other pretty successful barbecue I
don't know by you but I think that was
great yeah I expected Larissa to be a
sweet wonderful person
Nicole told me so much about why am i
laughing it's horrible but it's so funny
I don't know bro Larissa's the man of
the house I made a nice duper eraser but
she just wanted to be by herself and it
really kind of upset me okay mom oh
don't cry mom come over here
mom she'll lead us to come on mom see
see what I mean he makes it seem like oh
I can't leave my mom because III take
care of her she's taking care of you are
you talking about she cooks and cleans
and everything I can't leave my mom I'm
too young man so weird monster are too
attached to their son side I don't know
it's not healthy I don't need to call
you guys now
I go you're farting Jesus Christ dude
I'm trying to record videos here you
make a meal woozy so Larissa tries to
take over the situation she's gonna cook
for for a cult instead of mommy Debbie
oh I don't know eggs bacon hashbrowns
oh nothing good coke air you know when I
speak to cold
I lied to him about my cooking skills
because I thought what to me like sex
and good food doesn't usually work for
breakfast cold doesn't eat bread for
breakfast I'm his mother
Natalie I think that Scotty's wild so
you'll be good if he sometimes we make
something simple he don't even told it
to like him a king in the morning so
what do you want for breakfast tomorrow
[Music]
breakfast for the Vols like some what do
you want tomorrow huh I worry about that
tomorrow
I guess ideally liver sent my mother
could get along yes
yikes Oh God the cringe
she raised an extremely dependent son
it's so unhealthy water has more flavor
I spent two hours doing my makeup be
[Music]
sorry the dream couple how could this go
wrong Santa Coty and he still wants to
be coach wife so I hope if I I'm sweet
he can forgive me hello I'm fine I feel
like Larissa and I are two different
people or basically polar opposites
she goes from sweet to scary I decide to
put the ring back that's nice what are
you looking I'm the kind of flights to
Brazil myself
oh he's done I never thought that he'll
be so mean but it doesn't complement to
me
a real man shouldn't act like this it's
really awkward it's like oh goodness
what do we do that's already she spent
two hours I know that's what you want to
say anything it's not one time to time
every time you know look at my shirt I
work all day
oh god this is just funny maybe it's you
that crazy you're back crazy
I feel really embarrassed right now
Larissa has no right to start a fight
with me in front of my friends in pub oh
god I was just going to end I don't know
extremely well stop it
if the rest doesn't polarize my mother I
might have to make a very hard choice
between a life with Marisa and a life
with my mother
my man just ate my man just said that my
man just said that I'm not running clean
now there it is I watched a video of the
fight and the cousin started all called
the defender so she had to do it herself
right he didn't defend her oh you're
right damn people hate them on they'd be
so shady she tries to come off sweet
like a victim but she had such a bad
bite I feel like she's a minute I don't
I haven't seen any of this what are
people picking up daddy I have something
to say to you
oh you pregnant
hey I have you what did you know that
you have children
[Music]
cold sitting there like a concerned
teacher during a conference I'm sorry
his name is Colt II come on I am shop
[Music]
did they divorce yet so they can he can
finally marry his mother here's your
present masculinity oh my god alright
that's the last clip that's the last
clip that's all I know I don't know what
happens Thanks
and why do I care about this it's funny
I love this trench TV it's great hope
you guys enjoyed as well subscribe we're
trying to beat Coco melon become a
member and catch the live streams get
early access to videos ton of benefits
discord I really appreciate it's been
really fun to build like a sub community
on the channel thanks for doing that
appreciate all my floor gay members and
see you tomorrow
[Music]
it's time to race what was once
forgotten
what creatures fought spells and pull
troops awaits hope T is coming to
Nintendo's wait and remember it has a
very big peepee pre-order promotion I
mean a de mes checkbook birthday :
[Music]